we now have video footage from the
january 6th
trump riots in washington dc which
confirmed that a close ally
of radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene
was not only there but he was inside the
capitol building you might remember that
we previously
discussed that a gentleman named
anthony aguero was suspected of being
inside the capitol building and aguero
is a
known associate of marjorie taylor
greens he's a right-wing
i guess we'd call him like a right-wing
live streamer and activist
and when back in february cnn asked him
were you actually inside the capitol
building on january 6th
he didn't answer and he said you know
there have been videos posted
which i was supposedly filming from
inside the building but they were really
filmed by someone else he sort of played
coy and didn't answer
we now have videos of the riot in which
it is clear that aguero was personally
inside the capitol building
in the screenshot that we're putting up
on the screen from freedom news tv
you see aguero highlighted by a red
circle
on the left side of the screen clearly
inside the capitol building now aguero
has declined to comment on this
marjorie taylor green's office has not
yet responded to requests for comment
but this is now it's no longer
hypothesis it's no longer speculation
it's no longer theory
this is a confirmed trump rioter
who is also an associate of a current
pro-trump republican congresswoman who
has
been heavily defended and propped up by
the
former one-term president donald trump
marjorie taylor-green and aguero
previously worked on anti-immigration
issues they've been to pro-trump rallies
together
and i previously told you about videos
in which marjorie taylor green
referred to aguero as amazing
and as a friend and as cnn has reported
aguero has called marjorie taylor green
quote
one of my closest friends so now we know
he was there
we know that a marjorie taylor green
ally was in the riots
now what well the next question is
actually one that goes back to a prior
question that we still don't have an
answer to
were there current pro-trump members of
congress
who were involved in discussions about
the plans for the trump riot ahead of
time
were some of these pro-trump congress
people not merely
indifferent to the riots not merely
supportive of the riots after the fact
but were any of them
actually proactive uh participants
in the planning of the january 6th trump
riots
we don't know the answer yet there are
already
investigations into certain tours of the
capital that happened
in the days leading up to the riots and
we're still trying to figure out
why would there be any tours since the
capital has been restricted
because of the pandemic that doesn't
make any sense so many more questions
remain unanswered i guess is the way i
would put it now
the position of the right continues to
be
a a sort of conflicting mix of talking
points these were
fake trumpists who rioted on january 6th
but at the same time we heard from ron
johnson
that if they were real trumpists they
weren't a threat to
anybody like him because they are
patriots who wanted
what's good for the country which
conflicts with they weren't actually
trumpists
um and they also had no plans to do
anything wrong
except they did because just being there
was a crime
you know how the right loves to say
undocument
the all undocumented immigrants are
criminal aliens
because it's illegal to be here for them
being here
undocumented is a crime why does it
matter
what they were doing at the capitol just
forcing your way inside is destruction
of property and trespassing
as they like to say about undocumented
immigrants it's a
crime just to be there under those
circumstances but of course
very different rules apply to pro-trump
insurrectionists than to undocumented
people
coming over the u.s mexico border so the
next question is
will we i mean it's a question for you
it's a question for us to think about
will there be any definitive linking
of these pro-trump members of congress
to the planning and organization of the
january sixth riots and there's a lot of
speculation on this
there are investigations going on uh and
then
the the sort of follow-up question is if
there are pro-trump congress people
linked to the planning
of the riots will there be any
consequences
because if anything has become the sort
of default
norm in the united states political
world
it's that for many elected officials
particularly republicans because their
own party is unwilling to hold them
accountable
there's just no consequences for things
that in the past there would be
significant consequences for
let me know what you think and of course
we'll continue following the
investigations
today's show is sponsored by an
excellent audio book
called takeover how a conservative
student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audiobook from noah feldman it
just came out
and feldman actually narrates the
audiobook himself
noah feldman of course is a harvard law
professor and constitutional
scholar you may remember him from his
prominent role in trump's impeachment
number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country six of the nine
current supreme court justices are
current or former members of the
federalist society
and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for
its relationship with american politics
the federalist
society is an organization anyone in my
audience
should be aware of and the audiobook has
a ton of
excellent insight into it and the role
it plays i really enjoyed listening to
the audiobook i think anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover
by noah feldman the audiobook is just
4.99 and you can get it at
davidpakman.com
slash takeover or wherever you buy audio
books